okay let's talk music because of course
you um canceled your tour and as much as
we want to see Mandy Moore live
obviously your health comes first that
couldn't have been an easy decision for
you yeah you know we we did half of the
tour and it was fantastic and so much
fun and I you know I was on the road
with my husband and my brother-in-law
and we brought our son with us and it
was just magical it was also just really
physically exhausting to the point where
I was like this I have to draw the line
and really you know
um trust my gut and give myself some
Grace and recognize that I can't do
everything I think I just was really
pushing myself to the max
um and being six and a half months
pregnant at that point I was like I
can't really like I'm not resting and I
have to put my health and the health of
my family first and it was a really hard
decision because I didn't want to let
anyone else down I didn't want to let
myself down and this was something I had
wanted
you know for 15 years to go back on the
road when things were booked and and and
put out there I I didn't know that I Was
Pregnant and So I was like you know what
we'll we'll definitely check back in and
do this again when um I don't have a
baby in my belly that part so I feel
like this is the first time in quite a
few years that I've really like powered
down a little bit and
um just being a mom which is the hardest
job of all does Gus realize that he's
about to be a big brother
he doesn't we keep trying to tell him
baby breather and he'll say baby brother
but I don't think he has no idea what
that means um we'll see I'm excited all
right so let's talk about this because
what a lot of people may not know that
even though you have been responsible
for wetting my eyes uh you actually
suffer from dry eye disease
um that little Revelation is why we
teamed up with Mandy and luminous to
help educate people about the disease so
for years I have suffered from dry eye
disease which is a real thing that I
didn't even know that I had my eye drops
were just starting to not work as much
it was a constant frustration being an
actor and a performer like my eyes are a
really huge part of how I do my job and
I just thought okay
this is something that I'm gonna have to
live with but uh I discovered octolite
which is a light based treatment for dry
eyes it's quick it's comfortable it
requires no downtime I am thrilled with
the results and it's really just been a
total Game Changer in my life
foreign